I didn't expect it to be that loud.
I couldn't hear it.
What's going on?
It's a road sound!
Making pasta.
I always want pasta.
Also...
Tiz himself.
Thank you for the 10 gifted!
Welcome back, Master Tamagotchi!
I was surprised.
I was really surprised.
I don't think we watched this before, did we?
Witchcraft.
Oh, headless man!
Oh, just kidding.
Is that a boob?
Oh, pun.
Oh my god, space!
What is going on?
This is making me even more confused.
Oh, nasty!
Torture!
Math!
Oh!
Outer Wilds!
That's on the cover.
Came back from my vacay at Niagara Falls.
Back to Minto.
Yay!
Welcome back!
Eternal...
Oh.
Oh, never mind.
It's not eternal.
That's just for the second.
Huh?
That
confused me...
more than everything.
What?
I still don't know what this game is about.
Welcome back, everybody, to Eternal Darkness.
Sanity's Requiem.
My sanity has been...
revoked.
Math is the scariest part of the game.
That's what I'm saying!
It's loud, is it?
I can't tell...
which one you're hearing.
Sorry.
Is it okay now?
Wait, can you hear that?
Can you still hear the game?
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
You can?
You can still hear the game?
Oh my gosh.
No wonder it's so loud for you guys.
I'm so sorry.
I thought you were hearing it...
through...
well, then maybe...
if I do this, can you still hear it?
Thanks for the five gifts.
Sorry.
We're doing a soundcheck now.
You can still hear it?
Oh, perfect!
Interesting...
I'm learning things.
The adventures of Pius Augustus, our favorite lich.
Pius Augustus!
Okay, cool.
I learned actually...
So much from that, actually.
Have a good stream.
I thought it said good morning.
May I have a happy birthday?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Zennara.
The game is heavily inspired by H.P.
Lovecraft.
Not just his monsters, but the style of his writing.
I see.
I'm gonna be honest, you guys.
I am so...
Tired today.
I don't know.
Maybe because I...
I didn't sleep very well last night.
And yesterday I...
Streamed for like, what, five hours?
And then I recorded that day too.
And then I also recorded today.
So I'm...
So E.P.
I'm so E.P.
So I'm not sure how long I'll go.
We'll see once I start getting into it.
Maybe I'll start...
I'll...
I can't even speak.
Paragon.
Why is it...
What is the paragon?
Everybody keeps mentioning the paragon.
I wanna be in on the joke too.
Again, I'm really sorry about the sound.
I didn't realize where you guys were hearing it from.
So...
It's just some...
It's some...
Tech stuff on my end.
I thought...
But now I've learned.
So you guys actually helped me out a whole bunch.
You don't even...
You don't even realize it.
Paragon.
What's the paragon?
It will become very apparent what the paragon is.
Paragon.
RONAN, welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So...
Let's not waste too much time talking because...
Oh god.
I've already ordered...
I have a coffee.
I have coffee.
We'll see how far I can get.
Look, we're Anthony in 814 A.D.
The darkness columns.
Oh, it's right where we left off!
This is actually perfect because I can...
Whoa, cinema.
The darkness comes.
Anthony!
I'm gonna turn it up just a bit.
How do I run?
Nope, this is a stand.
Okay, this is how I select which arm and stuff, I believe.
I have to be like, head!
Right arm!
Left arm!
Get him in the nuts!
And then I run.
This is how I run.
Okay, nice.
Left trigger to run, yeah.
And so we're here in good old ye olde 1814.
We're trying to talk to this guy here.
We need to talk to Charlemagne because I think he's gonna get...
I think he's gonna get...
killeded.
This is one of my favorite games of all time.
You're one of my favorite Toofas of all time.
I'm so happy you're playing this game.
Ah!
Thank you, Rhoda!
Thank you!
Yeah, there was this dead guy over here.
What happened to him?
Anthony sees the body of a monk.
His raiment...
Raiment.
Turn off the game console.
Is that of his order.
Stained with blood that has seeped from many grievous wounds.
It's truly a disturbing sight.
Vivicore, thanks for the gift!
We just can't stop staring though.
We have like this gruesome...
morbid curiosity, right?
I'm a... I'm a good...
I'm a good...
I go to church, look.
I'm a good guy.
Haha!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
But I can't leave either.
This game...
We have to go upstairs...
So basically last time we...
Open...
The way he runs is so funny.
But we opened up this...
Whoa!
Secret passageway.
And I have to climb down and probably be bombarded by bozos.
That was a good alliteration.
Bombarded by bozos.
You got that scroll.
Oh yes!
How do I do this magic?
We also got the Tome of Eternal Darkness!
We got that!
Very nice.
I'm gonna make myself a weeb...
A weeb Ted smaller.
There we go.
Hey Min, thanks for the stream.
Really needed it.
Aww!
Thank you!
Last minute work has now destroyed my sleep cycle.
I have a three mile run in three or four hours.
Do you have to do the run?
We got this urn.
Not quite sure.
And then our...
Wait, no.
This is the scroll that we're trying to give to...
Charlemagne.
For some reason, we just can't knock.
We don't know how to do that.
Oh shoot.
Wait.
Is it under...
Spell list.
We know nothing.
We're kind of dumb.
Yeah.
Anthony does not have enough components to attempt to research spell...
He does not have enough...
That sounds like such an insult.
I want to start using that.
Oh, you just don't have enough components to attempt to do this at the moment.
Cat peeing on the rug in the early hours of the morning.
It's my fault.
I messed up my...
Oh, no.
Not the cat pee.
I'm so sorry.
Not that you have eternal darkness save on your memory card, you should probably go back to the Psycho Mantis boss and twin snakes.
Oh my gosh.
You're right.
We got some runes, though.
We got this one rune.
It says...
It's called the Circle of Power, but clearly not powerful enough.
We can't even do a quick spell.
Oh.
Okay.
That's...
So, it'll be on the D-pad.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, gosh.
I'm so not used to...
I never had a GameCube growing up.
So, I love how you said Tome of Eternal Darkness.
Oh.
I love how happy you said Tome of Eternal Darkness.
So, why...
Okay.
That's why.
Oh.
All right.
Now that I have saved, I have no fear of death.
Maybe.
Already?
Oh, my God.
No.
Sorry.
Let's get his arm.
Get his arm.
They get this other arm.
Take out his arm.
Finish him.
I
found a magical rune.
Rune!
Good job, Anthony.
How's the sound, by the way?
Oh!
Runes are the key element in creating spells.
By collecting and combining runes in different ways, different spells can be created.
Okay.
I'm gonna make a new spell.
Dang it.
I have a rune.
Question mark, question mark.
Sounds good?
Okay, cool.
Oh!
Anthony!
Oh my god.
I forgot the music is so freaky in this.
Oh!
Okay.
Try it.
Do you have a rune for me?
Ouch!
It's okay.
Wait, I don't have a way to heal.
Not like the last person.
Are you gonna come up too?
Okay, good, good, good.
Come here.
Come here!
Ha!
I'm getting pretty good at this fighting thing.
Good news, I got an interview tomorrow.
Oh my gosh!
So disgust...
Good luck, good luck.
Oh.
Oh my god, Anthony does not look well.
Oh my god!
Oh, it revealed a door.
Oh, I got you, I got you, I got you!
I got you, don't worry!
Hey!
Don't get him!
Oh my god, no, no, no!
Hey!
Chill, chill, chill, chill.
Go after this guy, here.
Go after his other arm.
There.
Go after his arm.
There we go.
No, no, finish him!
Did I save him?
Or...
Oh!
I got a torch!
Uh...
Can I only have one of these equipped?
Or...
Oh my gosh.
It's one or the other.
Wait, but they died by this.
What's that?
Broken green urn.
Oh, there's urns here too.
This function allows the player to combine two or more items from the inventory into one.
Mix.
Two thirds!
There's more of you.
I never cared for idle things, but recently I watched a 10 minute video on how the mix came to be.
Didn't get me with MGS yet, though.
I'll get you, I swear!
I'll get you, I'll get you, my pretty!
I don't know if that's...
Okay, assembled is like...
Assembled, I think, is a bit of a stretch.
You know?
It's okay, Anthony, don't worry about it.
Can I place it here?
Oh wait, maybe here?
Oh, I can just check it.
Fragments of a broken urn pieced together to form a crude hole.
Deep cracks mar its structure and while it is almost complete, it is far from watertight.
At least it can be repaired somehow.
Do you think the monk was supposed to do that?
That didn't mean...
I didn't kill him, though!
He fell!
He took one hit and fell!
I tried to save him, he should've...
Oh my god.
I wish I could...
Look at Anthony, he's staring at it.
Oh, is it coming this way?
I hear you.
Oh no!
I pushed him down the stairs!
Finish him?
There's no way to finish him.
Okay.
Magormor!
He was going to give you a long sword.
Oh shoot.
Oh well.
A carved stone tablet lies on the stone floor.
Maybe the guy should've just left.
Oh, let's pick it up.
Magical...
The codex.
Runes cannot be understood without a codex.
Without a codex, runes in your possession will remain a mystery.
What runes do I got now?
I'm smarter.
I have the codex!
Oh, Magormor!
I understand now.
I'm so confused.
That guy came all the way up the stairs just to see me.
Oh no!
What's wrong, Anthony?
Oh, he will look really bad.
Oh my god!
Look at these sassy guys.
They're fighting.
The girls are fighting.
I'm gonna sneak up on this guy.
Oh!
Can I finish him?
If I... hold on.
Because I'm gonna need more... what's it called, right?
I'm gonna need more sanity at some point.
So if I... finish him!
Switch it out, right?
Finish him!
Easy!
Yeah, so I just switch it with the... equip the torch and then we...
Nice!
I'll take that.
Oh, just kidding.
A red urn sits beside the fountain.
Lucky!
A filled red urn.
And we can fill up...
Oh, there's another...
What are you looking at, Anthony?
You're scaring me.
You're making me nervous.
A slab of etched stone sits on the pedestal.
Sanity is overrated.
Hahaha!
Drink the water.
A disturbing rendition of a monstrous devil!
Okay, buddy, calm down.
It's a statue.
It is contorted into what appears to be a fountain.
Or it was built that way.
It was carved that way.
What sickly liquid is this draining into the pool?
Trickling from a scum encrusted spout.
It's water, Anthony!
Chill out!
Anthony has never heard of water before.
Too medieval for him.
Wait, can I use the...
Let's see.
You clumsy!
While fumbling around, the urn slips from Anthony's stiff fingers, dashing itself into fragments as it hits the floor.
Anthony picks up the broken...
Wait, we got a rune in there!
Wait, maybe I was supposed to do that!
This one!
We still don't have that one.
Wait, can I make a new spell?
I think I have enough...
Okay, everybody, I have enough components.
I have the components.
Oh!
What did I make?
Oh.
I don't think I'm doing it correctly.
Uh...
Spell 1!
The effects of this spell are unknown.
Not all of its components are in your possession or have been identified.
Spell 1, baby!
We'll put spell 1...
Oh, uh...
Spell...
We're gonna assign spell 1...
to here.
Yeah!
Good job, Anthony!
One.
Spell 1...
Back away from last.
Dangerous.
Cast it?
Oh, what if it's like a...
Okay.
Oh!
Wait, but I...
Oh, select an item to enchant?
Scrassmasax?
Oh!
This magic...
magic meter represents a character's magical energy.
When a spell is cast, the level will get lower.
This meter regenerates whenever the character is in motion.
May the rats eat your eyes!
The darkness comes!
It will damn us all!
The rats!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Let's go... Okay, Anthony, you look really bad.
I'm sorry.
Oh.
This guy's really big!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Hey!
Chill out!
Okay.
God!
It's still enchanting.
I don't know what it's doing.
I think it's working.
Wait
for me!
I'm coming to...
What if you check it now?
Oh, good idea.
This Frank and Saxon weapon relies on a hefty blade to deliver deadly cutting and slashing attacks.
It does not have a handguard, as it was designed for offensive rather than defensive fighting.
Don't blame Anthony.
He's only ever had ale and beer since his mother weaned him.
Oh!
It opened for us!
Ah!
I see, I see.
So when we step on the platform...
An ancient stone tablet leans against the bookshelf.
Yeah!
Ale!
Yo, wait, what's that down there?
Oh, that's the blinking of my sword.
He's only ever had ale and beer.
I've been entertained by your mods for years now.
I'm finally tuning in live for Eternal Darkness.
Thanks for entertaining me all these years.
Thank you!
Amongst the books on the table rests an ancient scroll of what appears to be paper.
Enchant Item.
Oh!
Way ahead of you, game.
Cinderathalos, thanks for the 10 gifts!
I am way ahead of you.
I am so way ahead of you.
This allows the player to cast spells that have been found or researched.
Selecting this allows players to assign their most used spells to a button.
This will enable the casting of spells without having to choose them from the book each time.
Through this function, the player can examine the contents of each spell scroll that has been acquired.
Oh!
That which is broken shall be fixed.
That which is dull will be sharp.
Thus is the nature of the Enchant Item magic.
Oh, it's sharper now!
This spell requires Antorbock.
They sound like Pokemon for real.
Antorbock!
Magimor!
Okay.
I've already done it.
Thank you.
Oh no, it's taking me through the tutorial.
No, please let me out!
Let me out!
I can't...
Okay.
I'm gonna have to assign it there as well.
Okay, now I can leave.
Anthony, are you okay?
You're looking mighty green, buddy.
You're looking so bad.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys for all the super chats!
Thank you so much!
Finally got a job after being un-slash-underemployed for eleven and a half months!
Holy cow, cuddly.
Your streams are so helpful in keeping me motivated in tough times.
So happy I can afford to super my OC now.
No!
Save it!
You deserve it!
You earned it!
I want you to remember the Pokemon rules when it comes to your spells.
Oh!
Was that...
OBS?
I don't know what just went...
Am I still streaming?
That's what ties into three colored bars your character has.
Wait, what?
Pokemon rules.
I'm here?
I don't know what just happened.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, what did it say?
Religious texts on unspeakable nature, written in languages utterable only by monsters or corrupt humans.
Okay.
Open that up.
And now run for it, Anthony!
Run for it!
The bishop passed through the secret door.
There has to be a way to get through it.
Anthony, you look so dead.
Do I need...
some...
It looks like...
Mamito Gaming.
What else can you enchant?
Oh!
Oh my gosh, you're so right.
The things that we needed to be fixed.
Then also this one.
Wait, how's my magic looking?
Oh, it doesn't drain that much.
Although the urn appears to sit correctly in place of the pressure plate, it does not appear to be heavy enough.
We gotta go get the water.
We gotta...
Okay, Anthony.
Anthony, you look so...
buddy.
I'm really concerned for you.
He doesn't look good at all.
He looks like he's about to...
keel over.
There's something in here, right?
Yeah, okay.
Use!
Dunking the urn into the foul-smelling fountain, it becomes filled to the brim with rank fluid.
It is a lot heavier now, and rife with...
pho-tor.
Fetter?
Pho-fetter?
All right, let's get going.
And here it goes!
Thank you so much!
Let's all be reckless with our money.
Now!
Oh my gosh, Anthony.
I love your laugh.
Thanks.
Use...
Wait, wait, what do you mean?
It's not heavy enough.
Wait, all three of them will be heavy.
All three of them will be heavy enough.
It means stinky.
Ew!
It like...
just panning over to the already open door and like making the sound as if it like, you know...
Ooh, it's kind of spooky in here.
As if, you know, it wasn't already open.
Okay.
Am I gonna have to...
Wait!
I just noticed!
I'm gonna make it sharp!
I heard we're being reckless with our money.
I don't think so.
Oh!
Wait, he's alive.
Oh, no he's not.
I've come to return my book.
Very well, then.
For your efforts...
He looks kinda like me.
...a quick and merciful death.
No!
Oh!
Oh my god!
He's the guy!
Oh, gosh.
Get him!
Get his ass!
Oh my god, run away!
Run away!
Oh my god, run!
Cut off his arm, please!
Oh, I got one of his arms!
Nice!
I got his arm!
I thought he was gonna be a good guy...
You're not a good guy at all!
Finish him!
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Shoot!
Oh, there we go.
Anyway...
Run away?
Get his arm!
Get his ass!
Hoo!
The jukes!
Hahaha!
Ah!
Go, Anthony!
Get Anthony!
Anthony, my buddy!
Ew.
The Charlemagne's gonna see us and be like...
This is...
That doesn't seem like a good place.
What if we do put the book there, though?
Oh!
A shrine to a god that bespeaks of an ancient evil that graced the earth before mankind walked its valleys.
I'm gonna put the book there.
Oh, never mind.
I can't.
Touch the pedestal?
I'm trying.
Won't let me.
Do I go this way?
I guess now that we have the bishop key, we go back to Charlemagne?
Is that the door that it opens?
Oh!
Oh, god.
Anthony!
Oh, my god.
Anthony, no!
He looks like...
Charlemagne's gonna kill us.
Ah!
Holy!
Spooked me like crazy!
Yeah, take that!
Charlemagne's gonna kill me.
He kinda reminds me of...
I don't know.
For some reason...
The Sims or something.
I should've known.
Let's just get out of here, Anthony.
We don't need to fight.
Don't be greedy.
Who's coming at me?
What the hell is that?
Um...
Maybe it's a friend?
Yeah.
What?
I was just looking at Mokopis earlier and they look like a Mokopi.
The Trapper Dimension sprawls in every direction Whilst in this place magic cannot be cast And humans are subjected to odd phenomena The portals cycle from color to color As time progresses And only the quick will escape Um...
Um...
What?
Do I need to go to the blue light over there?
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Not the red one.
Blue?
I'm in the shadow realm.
For real.
Okay.
Let's go to the blue!
Oh, shoot.
There's a guy there.
It's okay.
I can get his ass.
Oh.
All I know how to do is hit rocks, man.
Get his arm!
Come on, his arm!
Wah!
Thank you!
Oh, wait.
My Dono's thing...
Hold on.
My Dono's thing is all my...
I messed up.
Wait, I can't see it!
Refresh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, there it is.
Wait.
There it is.
Everything is acting weird today.
I'm the ultimate wizard.
Slaps you limply with his arms.
That urn looks as good as new.
So true.
Okay.
There we go.
I think this is how I get out.
This looks healthy.
Oh!
Never mind.
I lied.
Uh, what's purple?
That looks like an exit.
For sure.
That has to be an exit.
Get out of here, Anthony!
You're turning into a zombie!
Yay!
Okay, so...
Avoid the scorpions, I guess?
Trappers have no eyes, but can sense sound very well.
If Anthony can sneak past them, they won't be troubled.
How
quiet.
Sneaking mission real.
Hit the door.
Oh my gosh, don't come this way.
I'm moving one pixel at a time.
Oh.
Yay!
Ah!
Oh my god.
Get the other guy!
Oh my god, there's three of them.
Oh gosh.
Kill them all!
Just strike them dead!
I wish I could get his head.
Yeah, there we go.
Take him out.
Enchant wore off.
We'll do it.
We'll fix it.
Okay.
La la la.
I don't think...
Surely, Charlemagne will be fine.
And there will be nothing that is attacking him.
I believe.
Oh yeah, let's do our magic.
Enchant our sword.
Oh, I forgot!
I should be using my torch instead.
The torch is kind of awesome.
Anybody here?
Not even a poor, sad, dead bishop.
Oh god, Anthony.
Oh no!
No, no, no!
Oh god, Anthony!
Even his hair is graying.
Oh gosh, buddy.
Oh.
He doesn't like the light.
Oh, he doesn't like the light.
Oh, interesting.
Okay, I'll re-equip my sword then.
Oh!
Cool!
He might be me.
Casually returns to the world of the living looking like this.
Oh buddy, I think you're...
Oh!
What the...
No!
You can go back down the ladder.
Thank you.
Yes, save and continue.
Okay, we're good.
It's the same picture.
I think it's still fine though, right?
It did save though, right?
Three hours and...
What do you mean, cheater?
It's again?
Cheater to anything.
Okay.
The time did change.
Okay, great.
Um, holy shoot.
Ah!
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh my god.
My game is in reverse.
Wait.
Or something?
What's happening?
No!
Oh!
Run!
Ouch!
Oh gosh!
What's happening?
Do I do...
Magic?
Where's this torch?
Equip this instead maybe?
Do you like this?
Take that!
I'm gonna die.
I'm about to die.
I cut off a piece of him.
I'm examining the...
How am I still alive?
Oh gosh.
I don't know what's happening.
How am I still alive?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Ouch!
The controls here are very weird.
Oh!
I killed him!
I don't know how...
I don't know how I won!
Let's go!
Zero sanity.
Not anymore!
Whoo!
Anthony, are you okay?
Oh shit!
Ah!
Wait!
No!
Please!
Anthony, are you okay?
Wait...
Was that part of the sanity?
Was that...
Part of the...
I even... I turned my control on and off.
That was a sanity effect?
No way!
Oh my god.
What?
Ah!
Ouch!
Don't kill me, please.
Please, don't kill me.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe I should have saved after...
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Please!
Ouch!
Run away!
Anthony!
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to...
survive.
Hold on.
You know what?
It'll be fine.
I am gonna save.
But...
We'll save in this slot.
Just save and continue.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
The torch.
You're right.
The torch would be better here, I think.
Yeah, and then we'll just switch it over.
What the?
He's tiny!
He's teeny tiny, skinny man!
Oh
my god.
But it's not letting me...
finish them.
I think they're too small.
Oh!
The game!
Ah!
Is it really happening?
Oh.
It's not?
Wait.
What's hap...
Yeah!
Oh gosh.
Anthony, don't die.
Okay.
What's going on?
What's happening?
Oh my god!
So when something is actually happening, it...
I... um...
I'm fine.
I can continue forward.
But something's not actually happening.
My sanity's being crazy crazy.
Oh my god.
Even the...
the... the... the tilt.
Um...
Okay.
Alright.
The bishop's key.
We have it.
Ooh!
...a
fool for trying to save him, Anthony.
His fate was decided many centuries ago, as is the fate of this world.
Colonel?
Despite your faith, there is little to save you from the power of...
Oh my god!
Was that Roy Campbell?
Oh my gosh.
Colonel jumpscare was so funny.
Anthony turned the game console off right now.
That's literally...
Oh my gosh.
That's so funny.
Okay.
We're back as... as she.
Oh gosh.
Wait.
Can I do spells now?
...
I can!
So what I learned...
...
Anthony was liquid!
Oh yes, I do remember that!
I swear to god, I heard...
There is... there is little to save you from the power of Shadow Moses.
...
We're all... we're all so brain-rotted.
Oh gosh.
Oh neat!
So now...
Okay, cool!
My sanity is getting a little freaky.
Second floor key!
Let's go!
...
What's that?
Here?
...
I'm scared!
Okay, the game is actually starting to scare me.
Hold on.
I keep adjusting the audio a little bit.
Because I think it's getting kind of loud.
...
What you learn in the book, you learn in real life!
I'm reading!
...
Oh gosh.
... Thank you!
The entire VA cast for this is just an MGS reunion.
...
I'm afraid of Skellyman coming out of somewhere.
I'm afraid of having to fight.
...
My sanity is not that low!
Hamburger...
Bang, bang, bang.
Ma'am, we're here to talk about your car's warranty.
Wait, is it the front door?
Hello?
Okay.
Weird things are going on in this place.
I mean, weird things have been going on.
Oh, is it this door?
...
Uh oh.
Wait, maybe we shouldn't.
...
Like AOL sound of the door closing.
Oh, what's this on the ground?
Oh, that's not what I thought I was examining.
Oh, this is a forest?
Okay.
This is a horse?
How can my Yoshi be this spooky?
Whoa, what was that?
Did you guys see that?
There was like blood or something!
...
Time has taken its toll on the surface which is...
which is soiled with dirt and scratches.
Us skellies are afraid of ghosts as well, so we're even.
Wait, you didn't see it?
Okay.
Oh, wait!
No!
You guys, it's right there!
And also, this guy was looking at me funny!
Hello?
We're just not gonna...
We're not even gonna address it?
... Huh?
We're just...
Okay.
We're just not even gonna talk about that one.
That's fine.
I'm looking up at something.
What am I looking up at?
What are you looking up at?
Everything's bleeding.
Grandpa?
You seem a little paranoid.
Just maybe...
I don't know.
Detail.
Alright.
Ooh!
Some runes!
One of the drawers in the dresser curiously has no keyhole, and it places a small triangular design flanked by a magical symbol.
What does it mean?
So I need to get that...
Oh, the bathroom.
There's a note in here.
Oh, Journal of Maximilian Ruyvis!
When are you going to start playing the game you've been staring all this time?
Are you muted?
That would be so freaky.
Do I have this one?
Let's check my spells.
My runes.
I don't have these runes.
Oh my gosh.
Legendary spells.
I don't care.
Okay.
Wait!
Was this here?
Was this swan here before?
This guy just staring at me.
Okay.
Maybe so.
What about you?
Grandpa!
Really good screams today.
I think it's because I'm tired.
This place is so big.
Napoleon.
Oh!
A chapter page has been hastily stashed behind the frame of this painting.
Should Alex retrieve...
Yes?
The gift of forever!
Oh yeah, we also have to read the...
The journal entry?
Let's see.
Check.
This is a page from Maximilian Ruyvis' journal.
It reads, Everything that brightened my life now engulfs me in darkness.
I fed on the light of truth, yet starved on the shadows of lies.
I have learned through my lifetime, but no less than a newborn baby.
That's exactly how I feel right now.
The gift of forever.
I want to keep exploring a little bit more before we go into the next chapter.
A musty aroma hangs in the air and a layer of fine dust...
Mike Tyson's ass!
Oh, sorry.
Eating Mike Tyson's ass!
Thanks for the fine gift!
Yesterday were good too.
She literally screamed for ice cream.
A layer of fine dust lies on all the surface of the room.
It seems as if no one has been in here for a long time.
It's almost like a museum.
It belongs in a museum.
Damn.
We got some revolver ammunition?
Uh-oh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
My sanity is not so low for it to be turning the screen like that.
My sanity is not so low for you to twist the camera around, okay?
Six shots.
Why does it allow you to look at everything?
I don't know.
Grandpa?
Can I also just walk through?
The wallpaper in this section of the hallway is oddly marred as though the wall it sits on is not even with the rest of the room.
Oh.
Uh.
Never mind.
Great grandpa.
Snail.
I was wrong about that.
It's too dark in here to do anything.
Perhaps the circuit has been broken.
Glad it left for us.
Just push it.
Just do something!
You can do it!
Just...
Just do something with it.
Just do something!
What?
Somebody's hungry!
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
There's a rune there!
I didn't even notice that.
I couldn't touch it.
The stained glass depicts a glowing medieval maiden.
Luminous.
Even with the faint light of the setting sun.
Setting sun.
The maiden clasps a piece of parchment.
The widow gives Alex a strange feeling.
Almost as if it is magical.
Not really there.
A glowing field of energy protects the window.
Okay.
Oh!
If you get real close to it...
The Sutting said.
I like her idle animation.
That's fun.
Okay.
There was one other thing I wanted to check before we...
Um...
Before we do the next chapter.
And that's this door.
Does this look different?
No, I think he looks the same.
Never mind.
Okay.
I think I'm getting really paranoid.
Is the door...
Was it in here?
Yes.
This is I think the same rune that's on the dresser.
Okay.
Stop it.
Alright.
Let's go to the gift of forever.
Who are we now?
Dreams.
Modern psychology offers only unproven theories.
Some see them as the meaningless tossing and turning of a brain...
settling into a restful sleep.
Others see them as laden with symbols of our unconscious desires.
To still others, dreams represent the upwelling of the archetypes...
normally hidden deep within the recesses of the human collected unconscious.
Of one thing I am certain.
After a brush with the ancients...
our dreams metamorphosize into nightmares.
Wait.
565 AD?
We went back in time?
We're in Persia.
Oh no.
Get this guy some water.
He's gonna start hallucinating.
I have implored you for years.
Yet you ignore all my advances.
You dominate my dreams.
Wow.
And I can think of nothing else.
I fear I desire you many hundred times more than you love me.
My life has become a woe to me.
No wonder he's desiring her!
If you truly desire me, as you say, then you will find this for me.
Bring this treasure to me and I will be yours.
Both of our dreams will come true.
She's just like Kaguya!
I need nothing more than you.
Oh my god.
You have enthralled me to the point where I can think of nothing else.
This guy is suffering from Symposis.
You will not forget about me.
I think she will.
You need not worry.
I desire nothing more than the treasure that you seek.
Leave now, Karim.
And I shall await you.
He's dreaming of her.
Symp!
He's like, this has got to be it.
Oh no, there's guys all around here!
Uh oh, they're going to start attacking me.
Good job!
You made it!
Oh, what do I have?
What is this?
Talisman.
An ancient talisman that has been in Karim's family for many generations.
It is said to bestow long life on those who have kept it.
This item can be used to restore health.
And chakrams.
The chakram was a favorite throwing weapon through central Asia in medieval times.
Karim isn't voiced by anyone from Metal Gear, but the girl he's simping for is voiced by Laughing Octopus!
No way!
A balanced ring of metal, sometimes beautifully decorated.
It would be hurled at an attacker.
Heavy chakrams could sever limbs or heads.
However, they were not designed to return to the thrower.
Oh, well, that's kind of...
But, what I can do...
Oh, I need the Tome of Eternal Darkness first!
Can I get that axe?
Let me get that axe, though.
A man's corpse lasts forever.
His eyes fallen.
Wounds cover the exposed flesh of his body, where his armor has failed.
Why is the music so... loud?
He's just dead.
The big guy and then the tiny little guy right next to him is so funny.
Sounds spooky down there!
Oh,
let's get our Tome!
Yay, I'm walking on you!
Oh, my gosh.
This is what I should do for you guys.
If you're just like, gosh, I wish Mint would step on me.
Actually, any VTuber.
Like, I wish VTuber would step on me.
Just line up.
There you go!
Built in what appears to be a leathery hand lies...
Excuse me!
A mysterious book!
It is bound in human skin and intricately decorated.
Excuse me!
With shrunken bones, it beckons and yearns to be possessed!
Yes!
Take the Tome!
Uh-oh.
They woke up.
Whoa!
That's a lot of guys.
That's a lot of guys!
Let's enchant my sword.
It didn't work!
Because I went outside the runes!
Interesting.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Run!
Yeah, let them fight!
Let them...
Take care of...
Oh.
Uh...
Finish him!
I think I got him.
There we go.
Because he's made of bones!
Is this like a skele...
Oh man, I missed out.
Can I leave?
Or...
What do you want me to do now, game?
Do I go back down?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
What is that?
Are these guys gonna come alive?
Yes, come over.
I didn't realize...
Oh!
I didn't realize that like...
Getting their head was so powerful.
I always thought getting the arms was better.
He wasn't tiny.
He was average-sized.
Yeah.
He was smaller than the rest, though.
The statuette, vaguely resembling a man, stands atop a low pedestal.
Oh!
It looks like Gru from Despicable Me.
Hurt his little feelings.
I didn't mean to.
Okay.
I guess that guy is fine.
Oh!
Come here.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Oh!
He's got a brood!
Let's save.
Thank you.
Oh!
He's confused.
Oh, God.
Am I good?
Wait.
What's happening?
Oh!
Violence is happening.
Yeah!
He kills them so haphazardly.
Let's see if I can save.
If it'll let me.
No!
It won't let me save.
It's too dangerous here.
Still?
Still too dangerous?
Is anybody else alive?
Darkness.
I did Karim so dirty with this picture.
Why is he the cross-eyed?
Oh!
What's going on here?
I can't tell what's happening.
Oh!
The lanterns are...
It's like a fire.
Okay.
Cool.
We have to do this before we continue.
What happens when you simp too much?
You go cross-eyed?
He's crazy in love, you guys.
He's crazy in love.
Oh!
Oh, the top one.
Okay.
I'm actually...
What is this puzzle?
I have no idea.
You know what?
Let's go.
Let's examine it first.
An arcane shrine dominates the room.
Brassiers surround its edge, while a larger one tops its summit.
No doubt each one would be filled with incense to facilitate prayer to insidious deities.
Okay.
Brassiers.
I'm kind of confused.
Oh, yes!
We got the new rune!
You're so right.
Also, let's...
Oh!
We have this guy too!
Seems particularly heavy for its size.
Maybe...
I wonder if it allows us to duplicate him.
New spell!
Item?
Wait.
Project?
Item.
Wait.
This is the same one that I did before, isn't it?
This one!
No.
Simping.
All for nothing.
No!
He's gonna get the girl, I believe.
Oh!
Do I do it this way?
No...
Oh...
I never get the girl!
He's gonna get the girl!
He's gonna get the girl.
Wait, but there was nowhere else for me to go.
Which is why I'm kinda confused.
Or was there?
La la la.
Dead end.
This guy will reanimate at any moment.
There was nothing in the first room, right?
I don't think so.
Nothing.
How is he supposed to get back?
He's finding the treasure.
And then he's gonna go back to her.
Was there a combination I didn't do?
Was there a combination?
I can't.
Oh wait.
Oh no.
Yeah.
There's only these two rooms.
He did all the combinations.
Okay.
Are you okay?
Buster.
Symbol on the barrier?
I don't think I can grab it though, right?
A chorus skating barrier blocks Karim's progress down the ladder.
His shimmering energy creates the vision of a rune upon its surface.
Oh I can't take him back!
He's stuck there.
I think.
Oh no!
Our statue!
Rune order does not matter, only correct magics.
Okay, okay.
That's good to know as well.
Huh?
Oh wait.
Oh, I just had to touch it.
No way, it was so easy?
What about this then?
What was the point?
Okay.
Where is the skelly?
That's me.
Oh.
Oh
shoot.
Oh shoot.
Take his head.
You.
No!
Don't take this yet!
Finish him!
Yeah Karim!
A statue vaguely resembling a man.
Pick it up.
Nice.
And...
I'll take that.
Yay!
Wait a second.
Climb down again Karim.
I have a question.
You can take the torch!
Nice!
Hahaha!
Oh my gosh.
I'm gaming now for real.
So now we can put...
...
This is exactly what learning kanji is like.
Hahaha!
Oh, what is that?
Karim, what did you do?
Karim.
Karim, not good.
Where do we go Karim?
Where do we go with this...
...with these guys all around here?
Karim.
Karim!
We're gonna get attacked!
No, no, no.
Just a box.
I'm gonna go to the center.
I'm gonna go to this thing.
Yes!
Just go.
Just go Karim.
Hahaha!
We did it!
Phew!
Oh, okay.
We can go back up if we feel like it.
I'm walking with a purpose here.
Go!
Cover it!
Who's that?
Lucky!
Hahaha!
No comment.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh boy.
Uh oh.
Lying in a pool of cold blood is a dead soldier.
He is a victim of an unseen battle.
Perhaps this man died from the claws of the monsters of this place.
It is difficult to tell.
This guy's got his own little thing here.
The man lies dead.
Anointed in blood from the ravages of a Tollwar sword.
The wounds deep in numerous seep fresh blood, precise yet powerful.
The result of a man's actions, not a monster's.
Wait a second.
What's my sword?
Oh, I have one too.
But mine's also a Tollwar.
Can I have both of them?
Kareem!
Can I dual wield?
I'm kitty to real.
Oh my gosh, look at me.
Yo!
Kareem is awesome so far!
Hahaha!
Someone asked, maybe I should change up the brightness.
I'm going to make it a little bit brighter for you guys, just in case.
Um...
Save and continue.
Okay, save.
Let's see how it is now.
Oh!
Oh my god!
No!
I took your sword!
Oh!
Ow!
What's the point of dual wielding if you're not fast enough?
Oh!
There it is.
Oh my god!
What the hell is that?
Oh
my god!
Push, push, push!
Am
I okay?
Is my health okay?
Alright, we're alright.
Patent on the sanity system in fact expired.
I didn't realize it expired, right?
So awesome.
Oh, what's happening?
Oh my god, Grandpa!
There are times when insanity takes hold.
And nothing seems right.
During those times, I will help you.
Grandpa!
Am I insane?
For I will keep the darkness away.
Grandpa!
Grandpa, I'm reading!
This isn't really happening.
Is it?
Oh shoot.
Oh my insanity.
Come on, get the head, get the...
Oh!
Oh my
gosh!
What the hell is... Oh my gosh!
These things are so crazy!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I just took out that guy.
And now, whatever this thing is...
Okay.
It's dead.
Oh my insanity is really bad!
What happened?
What happened to my insanity?
I think they're called bone stealers.
Do these guys, like, make me...
Do these guys drain me, it seems?
Another dead man.
Who were these men whose corpses litter the dungeon?
Unwary soldiers who stumbled inside, or grave robbers looking to plunder it?
A crumpled scroll lies under the dead man's curled fingers.
Recover?
Green guys drain sanity.
Ah!
What did I just get?
The map's looking a little sussy.
New spell.
Wait.
Spell list.
Check.
A tattered scroll from an ancient text.
It reads The spell enables the transfer of magical power from the environment to the self.
Restoration of the body, spirit, and mind is in its purpose.
Noracath and Santoc.
Noratoc.
Oh, I don't have... I don't have those.
No!
This game...
Oh my god!
That's me!
Oh!
Shoot!
Oh, there's a lot of guys here.
Let's take them out one by one!
Finish him!
Ksha!
Turn the game console off now, Raiden!
Oh!
Wait, so if I touch this...
Touch.
It worked before!
You picked green at the start of the game.
You fight more insanity-draining monsters in this playthrough.
Oh!
Wait, that's...
I actually prefer that because I like to see the sanity effects, I'm not gonna lie.
But if my sanity gets too low, it says I start to drain health too, right?
Wait, I can't even save in here!
Oh my gosh!
I didn't even notice this!
Stinky!
Uh-oh.
Uh...
No,
I need to go to purple.
Purple!
Oh, purple!
No, not red.
Uh, purple!
My insanity!
Uh
-oh.
Finish him?
Oh no, stop.
Are you kidding me?
Raiden, get out of here!
Uh-oh.
I just tried to save the game.
Now it'll let me.
Okay.
Um, this isn't great, but, uh, cool!
You're doing just fine.
Hehehehe.
He freezes me!
Ow!
Get him, get him, get him, get him!
Get him, get him, get him!
Oh
gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
This thing.
Use?
Hahaha!
What just happened?
Oh!
It was a...
Wait!
No, I was supposed to heal!
Oh gosh, I'm so done.
I'm so dead, I'm so dead.
I'm so dead, I'm so dead!
Run, run, run!
Get out of here!
Open the door!
Open
the door!
Oh my gosh.
I thought that actually happened.
Oh, okay.
No, I think I'm gonna have to do it from here.
Okay.
Still missing an arm.
I can get this.
Get his arm, get his arm, get his arm, come on!
Oh my gosh, please.
It's so hard to aim.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, please!
Get the... I'm trying to aim for the arm.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it's happening.
Please, just find him!
Just find him!
Oh gosh, I'm gonna die again.
This is it, this is it for...
This is it for Kareem!
Just kidding!
Get out of here!
Oh, there we go.
Get behind him, okay.
I'm gonna use all my health in this one fight.
If I have to reload, I will.
But...
Now, um...
Embarrassing.
Finish it, please!
I need the insanity!
Magical Codex!
Holy cow.
I'm gonna save, but like in this slot.
Just in case.
Since we have very few health left.
Um...
New spell.
Wait.
Spell list.
What do I have?
What are my runes?
We need...
Narakoth and Santok.
This one, probably?
Woohoo!
Oh, my sword!
You're right!
We shouldn't...
Spell
the...
Um...
Hello?
Uh...
Spell list.
Oh, there we go.
Assign.
Recover.
There we go.
Enchant item, recover.
Yes, we should totally, um...
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
We'll do this.
We'll enchant our sword.
Oh, my sword.
Yippee!
And then we'll...
Recover?
Oh, shoot.
I have no magical energy.
Yay!
Oh...
Yeah, I gotta keep moving.
That's right!
Wait, open the door?
Oh, okay.
Wait, huge?
Am I huge?
Am I humongous?
Or is it just me?
The sanity effects are so funny because some...
Oh, but look at that.
It still went away.
Even though it, like, reset the...
room.
Can I recover now?
Then call Santa.
Give me all.
Ooh!
Let's do it again.
Then call Santa.
Give me all.
Wait!
I'm not recovering health?
Oh.
That's a little silly.
There's also a room in here.
It does literally nothing.
Metallic plaque replaces the lock.
A colored sigil is engraved on the metal above the wide slot.
The slot appears to be wide enough to insert a large blade.
Don't I know that one, though?
Recovering mana with mana.
What is this?
I thought I was recovering health at least.
What did I...
Oh, I think I'm talking to myself again.
Stone tablet!
The aged ceiling has collapsed, creating an impassable pile of rubble that blocks the doorway.
I don't think I have a lot of runes.
Wakan with a purpose.
He's like, I'm here to get my girl!
Oh!
The Dutch angle is...
He's doing what the gay.
Cinematic.
Of course.
I guess I'll grab that and regret it afterwards.
Sorry, I'm save scumming now.
That's me!
Karim!
It's got an eyeball on it and everything.
That's quite a few guys we got here.
Check it.
A formidable weapon that enables the user to strike many enemies at once and still keep a distance.
With a sweep, Karim can knock down enemies and can cause extreme damage with an overhead attack.
Let's go.
Oh gosh.
Run, Karim.
I don't know where to walk.
Finish him!
Nice.
Oh gosh.
Ouchie ouchie.
Finish him!
So much sanity.
Yummy sanity!
Sanity, sanity!
Oh no, my sanity!
Wow, that was so easy.
Holy cow!
Guts mode?
Oh.
Again, again!
Hahaha!
They're draining my sanity like crazy though.
Even the sanity that I get back is drained.
I'll drain...
Oh no!
All the sanity I get back is drained.
Hahaha!
Again, again!
No, stop draining my sanity, please!
I need it!
The music just stops.
Let me spot you some sanity.
Thank you!
Is that it?
Oh my gosh.
More?
Oh, this guy's got a rune!
Oh my gosh.
Stop taking my sanity!
Oh, it's a big guy.
I forgot that I can...
Yeah!
Wait, my health!
Ah!
Oh, it's this thing.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Please.
Oh my god, no!
Oh my god!
Hit it!
Please!
Oh gosh!
Kareem!
Oh, I hate these skinwalker things.
They're so gross!
Oh my god, please!
Oh my gosh!
Oh, I'm not gonna make it!
I'm not gonna make it!
No, please!
Kareem!
I'm not gonna make it!
Oh, I'm not gonna make it!
I can barely run!
Oh!
This thing is faster than me!
Please!
Please, just die!
Oh god.
I can't...
I can't hit it!
Oh, please!
It's too...
It's too squiggly!
Oh...
Oh, gosh!
Oh, it's dead, but...
So am I!
Aim!
No, it's...
It's literally...
I think it's literally because it's like...
How do I describe it?
It's like...
I think I can't get too close to it, you know?
I don't know.
I can't...
I aim for it, but it's just...
Oh, my gosh.
It went away.
One HP in a dream, baby.
Kareem has perished at the hands of the eternal darkness.
With no one to stop their diabolical plans, humanity will surely be annihilated.
The end!
Of course, the little...
Stupid stick man comes out!
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, it's so frustrating.
It's okay.
We saved right before it.
Ah!
The darkness comes!
Oh, Kareem!
Chakrams...
Oh, for those things?
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh, no!
Let's go!
I want to enchant it, but I don't think I can.
I think they'll get me first.
Oh, shoot.
Where am I?
Oh, God!
I can't see where I am, you guys!
Ah!
Close.
Not far enough, I guess.
Where?
Um...
Oh, my God!
Please!
Ah!
Take him out!
Oh my god.
Kareem?
Kareem, we were doing so well before.
What happened?
Kareem, you're losing...
You're losing your edge, buddy.
Oh my god.
You only got
the one guy.
Are they infighting?
No.
Come on!
Take him out!
Go.
Finish him.
Okay.
Here we go.
Okay, Kareem.
We're okay, Kareem.
We got this.
Come on, Kareem.
Even if it's just one more...
We got this.
Finish him.
Okay.
Heal now?
That's a good idea.
Oh, that gave us a lot.
Nice.
He's right next to me!
He's right behind me.
Isn't he?
Oh my god.
Holy cow.
Yeah!
Now we're gaming, Kareem!
I'm trying to finish him, but...
I'm trying.
There we go.
Hopefully that counted.
Finish him!
This guy over here, headless.
Unable to...
He's so unsure.
You okay, buddy?
They don't even count him as an enemy.
The music stopped.
Oh, just kidding.
Get up!
You still got some fight in you!
Oh,
enchant!
You're right.
Oh, I did the wrong thing.
There we go.
Okay, enchant this.
I wonder if it still worked.
Yeah!
Wait, are these the guys?
No, not yet.
Can
I finish this guy here?
Finish him?
These gangles are so bad for measuring distance.
It's really... It is tough.
Oh, you're still up!
You did it!
Overhead all these fools.
Yeah, baby!
All right.
Maybe I should take him out first.
Because...
The other guys...
They transform.
And I don't want to deal with them.
Where did he go?
Hello?
Are you still over here?
Are you still lying down?
Where did you go?
Oh, there he is.
He was lying down.
No way.
Can I leave?
Wouldn't that be hilarious?
Okay.
I haven't used this new thing.
So, I'm nervous about it.
Rip and tear, man.
Rip and tear.
I'm nervous.
Check the spells.
New spells.
Self.
Is that it?
Recover.
Now does it...
Wait.
But it's not in the thing.
Recover green flavor.
Yeah.
But like...
I have to do it afterwards.
I think.
I don't...
Unless I can do it over here.
No.
I just recovered more mana.
Hey.
Why didn't it work though?
Okay.
Now...
Wrong alignment?
Oh.
It didn't assign it.
But it's also not in here.
Okay.
Let's try this.
It's not under my...
Assign.
Oh!
I see.
I see how it works.
Okay.
That makes more sense.
Maybe actually I should assign it to Y.
Paragon.
Par...
Are we paragoning?
Okay.
This thing, right?
The chakram.
I'm scared to use it.
Unless... do you think the torch will work too?
Oh
my gosh.
Don't just stand there, I guess.
No, it does not.
Great.
Good to know.
Awesome.
Why did I allow both of them to come out at once?
Oh my god.
Oh no, no, no.
Okay, here we go.
Here goes nothing!
Please don't die.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please, I can't tell where this thing is!
Oh, I got it.
Oh my god, please.
I'm gonna die.
Oh, so close!
So close!
Oh, thank god.
Well, my health is...
Not great.
Here we go.
I lived somehow.
But not very...
Okay, I'm gonna move on.
My heartbeat.
A win's a win.
Yeah, but like...
If I can't make it out...
If I have to go through it again...
I shouldn't... I shouldn't have... I don't know why I let both of them come out at once.
That was... That was me just not thinking.
But, you know...
I'm slow...
I'm steady...
Save?
Yeah, you're right.
Well...
I'll save in this one.
Because...
If I feel like I can't...
Continue...
Because my sanity is way too low...
Then it would be bad.
Or not sanity...
You know, my health is what I meant.
Where did I...
Oh, this way, right?
Yeah...
There was that door we need to open.
Okay...
We were hobbling along.
Um...
I thought maybe if I cast it in front of the door...
It would work.
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
Karim places the blade in the slot, but feels it push back.
It is as if the magic of the blade does not fit the lock...
Oh...
Okay, we need to...
We need to make it green.
New spell, baby.
Um...
Item...
What was the other one?
There we go.
Item spell.
I love item spell.
Uh...
Cast item spell green upon the sword.
That's how we open it.
Oh...
Oh, wait.
I forgot to...
Fuse.
Green apple flavor.
Is this a door over here?
Kind of looks like it would be one.
Oh, my gosh.
My health.
Karim, you're worrying me, buddy.
Oh, gosh.
I got you.
Ah, don't finish him!
Wait.
Karim...
Ha.
Whew!
Yeah, we are so sane.
Um, I think we're...
I'm like...
I am so aware of the world right now.
I am so sane.
I'm...
I am... I am... Maybe I'm not as sane as I thought.
I've taken my moods!
I know that there's a ladder right there.
I'm just seeing if there's anything.
I wish this game had, like, health.
Here we go!
I thought they weren't able to hear.
You can take my sanity.
It's fine.
It's fine if you take my sanity.
I don't need it.
I'm good.
Any chakrams left?
No.
I'm so sane I'm seeing the player through the screen.
What is that?
What's that action figure?
A ruby effigy stands upon the pedestal centered in the room.
It's mine now!
What do I do with this?
A small statuette of a defeated warrior.
That's me!
Kneeling in respect to an unseen victor.
It is made from a deep red ruby.
Okay.
Is it Anthony?
Oh no.
No, no, no, no.
Go ahead.
Take my sanity.
Whatever.
Just don't trap me, please.
Do I leave?
Is there anything else in here?
I guess I leave.
Another simp just like me?
Okay.
Trappers can sometimes be helpful.
If I go into the shadow realm, does sometimes there's health?
You know how there was like a magic restore thing?
Is there sometimes a health restore?
I'm a little... I'm afraid Little Caesar's crazy bread is currently just regular bread to you.
Oh yes?
Should I go then?
Oh my god.
There's not that many guys here either.
So red?
Maybe?
I can't see what's over here.
Makes me a little nervous.
Go to red.
Wait, was that a guy?
Yes, it is.
Hello.
Hello, sir.
Can you see me?
Oh.
Shoot.
I think I got him.
Oh, yeah baby!
Oh my gosh!
It worked!
Wait, what is purple?
Oh, purple is to leave.
Oh my gosh!
Okay, so this is how the trappers work.
Interesting.
And now we're like basically...
We're basically Gucci.
We're so good.
Nice!
I'm so healthy!
Oh, are you still alive?
How?
How are you still standing?
He's like, I'm still standing.
Oh, that was great!
Okay.
Oh.
I'm so healthy, maid who's already dead.
Kareem is healthy.
These are kind of cute.
Here I go in slow motion.
Trapper.
I hardly know her.
I hope you're not.
Okay.
Walk.
Yippee!
Oh, Kareem!
I'm so happy for you!
Now...
Now what?
We have this little... We have our figurine.
What do we do with them?
Oh, save?
That's such a great idea.
You guys are so right.
In fact, I'm gonna go over the first one.
Since we're so back, baby.
Since we are so back, baby!
Where do I go from here?
Hold on, I'm checking the map.
Control pad...
Oh, C stick.
Oh, here we go.
We are so back, baby!
I think you can continue down the hallway?
This one?
Oh.
This one.
This is the second one.
I don't think so.
I'll check again though.
Doesn't hurt.
Oh.
Along the length of the corridor, the ceiling has given way and collapsed, littering the floor with debris.
Oh!
Climb!
Ah!
What's there?
Oh!
It's this guy!
Oh my god!
No!
You're just a normal enemy now!
That's messed up!
Oh shoot.
Come on!
I'm trying to get your... I'm trying to get your arm!
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
My... my...
He's taking out my magic!
Oh my god!
Whoa!
That's a big ol' boost.
Magic is fine though.
We just can recover.
This is why we save.
Yeah, we'll just run around.
We're good.
But my health is already halfway.
That's insane!
Blue weak to green.
Wait, so because I chose...
Because I chose green at the beginning, I'm basically like a grass type.
And so that's why I can kill him quickly?
Or... wait... do I...
You need the green encha... yeah!
If I enchant it because it was blue when I enchanted it blue.
And then green...
This game is so much more complex than I thought it was... like...
In a good way, you know?
Like...
There's so much more to this game than I...
And because I see... mostly...
Wait, what was my... hold on.
Because I see mostly... green guys, I should keep my weapon blue.
I decided to play this again since you started it.
I ended up dying twice in a later chapter where you have a shotgun because I was impatient and rushing with traps.
Always be patient.
Thank you for the reminder.
Oh wait!
Red!
Okay, red beats green.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I get it, I get it, I get it.
Oh!
What a peculiar room.
What the hell is this?
A blasphemous sculpture made from human skin and bone.
A trestle of bones is cradled within this shrine like a nightmarish book stand beckoning to be used.
I have a thing to put it there.
There you go!
Oh, I got it back?
Nice.
This looks really ominous, so...
This looks quite ominous.
This looks quite scary.
Is this like a final boss?
This game is Lovecraft Pokemon.
Oh!
Woah, what's happening?
Woah.
It's draining my sanity as we speak!
Finish him!
Oh!
There's more coming.
Oh, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Wait!
Oh, is this the same room again?
Wait a second.
Ow!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh, the girls are fighting!
Oh.
There we go.
Finish him!
Oh, wrong guy.
It's okay.
Finish him!
Oh, woah.
My sanity though.
My sanity.
I like how the music stops.
I'm like, oh, this part's over?
Or...
Nope, not over.
Just, you know...
Just being a little goofy silly.
Finish him!
Oh my gosh.
Run away!
Oh!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh, gosh.
Finish him!
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Just kidding.
Are you gonna also explode into a Skinwalker?
Oh my gosh.
This guy again.
I wish I had health.
Uh...
Oh, gosh.
This guy's not dead!
Oh, no!
Oh my gosh.
I can't...
He took me out!
He took me out so fast.
Yo, what?
Oh my gosh.
He took me out so fast!
Wow.
Um...
If only you had read the game manual before playing, you would know the strats.
Wait, I can't tell if you're being serious or not.
I can't tell if you're being serious or not.
I saved a...
Oh, this one.
Okay.
Yeah, if only you had read the actual game manual.
Gosh.
Everybody does that nowadays.
I hope it's a joke.
Okay.
Here we go.
I can't tell what this border does.
Oh, wait.
I take out these guys.
Finish
him.
Eternal Dwarf.
Shut up.
What is this?
Why is everybody picking on me?
Oh.
And
then these guys.
Oh.
My bad.
Okay.
Finish him.
Be fast about it.
Be quick about it.
Finish him.
Going down to the...
Yeah.
I'm getting the strategy guide.
If I do this...
You are sent to Celadon.
It didn't work.
They say don't move during those.
I can't tell if it had been completed or not.
Finish him.
Oh, gosh.
Why is this...
Why this camera angle?
Please.
I can't see anything.
You'll hear a sparking sound if it didn't work.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
That's it.
I'm in a bad spot.
This area sucks.
Oh.
Maybe this area isn't so...
Maybe this area is not so bad as I thought.
Just spam it.
Finish him.
Oh, no.
No.
Finish him.
The cheese zone.
Uh-oh.
Oh, here it comes.
Is this the big...
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
There's still another guy.
That I have to take out.
Wow.
This guy is coming after me.
Oh.
Ouch.
My san...
Oh.
Oh, my sanity.
Oh, my gosh.
You are sent to Celadon.
Go for the eyes.
Come on.
Kareem.
I need you to...
I need you to aim, buddy.
Oh, gosh.
Kareem.
Let's go behind him.
Buddy.
Let's go behind him and take out an arm or something.
Okay.
Nope.
Oh.
Missed the reach.
No.
I keep dying to this one guy.
Oh.
No.
It's so hard to see sometimes.
The reach, though.
It looks like I'm reaching him, but...
Hmm.
Good for the chakrams?
Okay.
Ah.
It sucks that I have to keep doing the same battle over and over again, though.
Darkness comes.
Can't aim because he only has eyes for Chandra.
So, yeah.
I guess maybe enchanting gear.
Oh.
Wait.
I just...
I just realized...
Never mind.
This
one makes it sharper, right?
Like, it's supposed to make your weapon sharper?
Or is it...
It only works against...
Oh, wait.
So, it actually doesn't even help?
Are you guys getting it out?
Or...
What is this?
Oh.
It does help, just not as much.
Okay.
Bonus damage.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Because I took out those guys in one hit, which usually I do not do.
Finish him!
So, it is...
I think it is technically stronger, maybe a little bit, but...
It looks prettier now.
It looks like an enchanter.
So, let's...
I just did a Minecraft weapon.
Just keep spamming!
Oh, I caught him!
Oh, these guys are getting back up!
Oh, it's just you guys.
Okay.
Finish him!
Run, run, run, run, run!
Oh my god!
It screws up my controls!
Oh gosh!
There's two of them though!
Wait.
Hello?
What?
I one-shot him!
Yeah!
Finish him!
I did it!
Yippee!
I got Sanctus Seladon!
Your Honor, she is cracked!
Oh.
Um.
My gaming activates in the weirdest ways.
My health is not so great, but whatever.
Wait, so...what is this?
Oh.
Hi, Karim.
Shaped like a delicate dome.
A pale blue statuette floats gracefully above the pedestal.
Should Kareem claim this artifact?
Yeah.
If I find it, it's mine.
Kareem.
We will be together forever.
Chandra?
Chandra!
What happened to you?
Things change, my dear Kareem.
But even though my body is ravaged, I await you.
Who did this to you?
You were gone so long.
Wait, how long was I gone for?
Chandra!
And in cruel revenge...
You!
Oh my god.
As the last blades were drawn across my body...
You wench!
She cursed that I would only be with another in death.
So much for thinking only of me.
Oh, you talent!
You!
I have seen my folly and have already paid dearly.
You talent!
I see so much more now.
In death, I know the true value of the artifact which I asked you to find.
She's not even thinking of me still.
And it is none for us to possess.
If we are to be together again, you must make a sacrifice.
She's just like, thinking of only one artifact.
Sacrifice?
Why should I do anything for you?
You lied to me.
Betrayed me.
And you really don't deserve me anymore.
You must forget the past.
Oh, girl!
Despite who you are now, you will also become something more.
Just as I have.
But the sacrifice must be made.
We must remain here and guard the artifact.
Dark things will come to claim it.
And you must be strong to keep it from them.
Without your sacrifice.
I think she's cuter this way.
The world will fall into eternal darkness.
Eternal darkness!
The things I do for love.
Okay, courage, the cowardly dog.
That's what would happen if you kissed me too.
I'd put glue in your mouth.
Or something like that.
I don't know what just happened.
What the heck is going on?
I'm gonna fix my sanity.
Since apparently, Alex is not doing so well.
She is a little...
Nice.
You guys are sick.
Is this the...
Some kind of mask.
Oh, it's serene.
I was thinking of the one from...
What's it called?
How the guy was just like, it's contorted.
It's disturbing.
It's spitting out blood from its...
It's spitting out something disgusting from its mouth.
I thought it was the same thing.
But no, this guy is serene.
And like...
You know, he's chilling.
Now, we can go...
Wait.
Actually, I'm not sure if we can open that door.
I don't know if we have...
The runes.
There's also...
This room here.
Give it a shot.
Okay.
My sanity is normal though.
Hello?
What just happened?
My sanity?
Is fine?
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for all the Super Chats!
You got any artifacts you need us to find?
No reason.
Kareem's pain at the end there is basically what we experience every time Mint is late.
No.
It's a hundred times worse.
When I'm late.
Who was found?
Super Chat.
Super Chat if you let Mint blue in your...
I hate this!
Oh, it is green.
Just kidding.
I'm not going to quick spell it since...
On you.
Gladius.
Enter my heart.
After this I have no mouth and I must scream.
Now we can use it.
For some reason I kept thinking it was purple.
Oh.
What?
It's not even a room.
Dirt.
Among the pantry contents is a spice jar with a scrap of paper hidden inside.
Spice jar!
She got us blue.
The kitchen is as empty as the library is full.
It's a reflection of her grandfather's attitude.
Always learning, reading, studying.
Rather than eating.
Maybe that's why you died, grandpa.
Peepaw.
If you have to rank them so far, where would you put the stories?
I actually really liked Anthony's.
So far.
I thought that one was kind of fun.
Let's check our spice jar.
Firmly sealed glass spice jar.
The faint aroma of Arabian spices is tantalizingly emanating from it.
There's a piece of paper inside it.
Yes, we shall...
Oh!
The lurking horror!
Oh boy!
Did you get the red statue?
I did!
What's happening?
This looks like the shadow realm we were at.
My
liege.
The future is yours.
The light in the age of darkness has been extinguished.
The pillar of flesh has been constructed.
The master of chaos.
The keeper of the ancients.
Is long dead.
The planets will be in alignment soon.
No!
All is prepared for your arrival.
Oh no!
I will begin the final incantation.
That will bring you into our world.
Within days.
Days?
The next millennium will truly usher in a new age.
Your guardians.
Now prepare the gate.
Favorite chapter, favorite character.
By the way, you can examine the weapons for details.
Wait, is the spice jar one of your favorites?
What do you mean?
Roses are red.
Mint's kisses are blue.
Like all these wisps.
I'm a simp too.
Hahaha.
Okay, okay.
Let's calm down a little bit.
Let's...
We're not...
Oh, that's my body.
Oh my gosh, I thought there was a person standing behind me.
Woo!
After playing this game back in the day, my friends and I adopted.
New term for crazy classmates.
Slightly slanted.
Hahaha.
The flesh pillar.
We have a...
Ew.
It's whispering to us.
We still have this dresser key.
That I haven't used yet.
I wonder if I can go find it.
Maybe...
In one of these rooms up here.
Oh.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
It hissed at me.
The statue isn't moving anymore.
Because I'm not crazy.
Crazy!
The door took that first leap.
That's what I'm saying.
Oh!
I got more ammunition.
Nice.
I don't know how I found that.
But very cool.
I don't see any...
Or rather...
Wait!
No, it said it has no keyhole.
Do I enchant the key?
Let me try...
Enchanting the key.
Oh, it can't be...
Enchanted.
Okay...
I need a keyblade.
I don't have those runes.
Yes I do!
This one?
I have this one.
Hmm...
What's that baby...
What are those babies doing there?
What is going on in this painting?
Why is the...
Why is the baby flailing?
Woohoo!
Spring break!
I feel like I can do this.
I need a drawer for some means of unlocking it, but...
Can find none.
However, the key is definitely a dresser key.
Okay, so maybe we can't...
Do that one yet.
Create a spell?
I wonder if we...
Do we have the rune...
Do we have the runes for it?
Item...
No.
Nope.
Item...
Projection?
This is the one we made before, isn't it?
Absorb item?
Oh no.
Wait, what did I just make?
Oh no, this is the...
Okay, just kidding.
This is the one.
Item... Absorb!
Enchant the key?
It wouldn't let me.
I tried already.
Unless...
Enchant item.
Cast.
Green.
Yeah, see?
This item cannot be enchanted.
Hmm...
Mysterious.
So mysterious.
Okay, well we know where it goes to now at least.
Or maybe.
It did say it's a dresser key and...
That was a dresser.
And that's the only thing we have...
To open.
I believe.
Also, I like how it says this room is basically a museum.
Isn't that a phone right there?
And it's on.
And also, this lamp is on?
Someone's definitely been in here.
I mean...
Cast green spell near the thing?
Okay, let's try it.
What, like the one to restore my sanity?
What,
like the one to restore my sanity?
Well,
alright.
Let's go read this chapter, I suppose.
Yeah, I don't have the right spell.
That's what I'm figuring.
Okie dokie.
Wow, it's already been two and a half hours.
What, we've gotten through two stories?
How many chapters are there?
What's it come from?
How had my ancestor stumbled upon it?
The Lurking Whore.
I feverishly began to read more.
Eager to learn his story.
It seems that Maximilian had inherited his father's mansion.
The best chapter?
Just as I had.
Alone since the death of his wife.
And since his children had their own adult lives.
He explored the house to discover his family roots.
It's the next chapter.
What, the one with the gun?
It has been two weeks since the death of my father.
And it has finally come to me to look over the mansion.
Now, I am truly alone.
I am forced to start a new life here in Rhode Island.
I intend to make the mansion mine.
And live in it as my forefathers have.
Wait!
To continue the family tradition.
Get this guy a chair, please.
A mansion has its secrets, I'm sure.
And in my time here...
I have to make them...
mine.
The viewers and chat are discussing a variety of different topics.
Some are talking about weapons and spells being used.
While others are discussing the streamer's baby in background art.
My baby!
Oh boy!
I got some pist... oh no!
A desk cluttered with notes and writs.
It's mostly business to do with the Roivis estate.
Is this like the... the witch?
The witch trials?
Small collection of Maximillian's medical journals.
References and reports.
Can I take that?
The music?
Is that my dad?
That's George Washington?
Mr. Washington?
I'm forced to be here on Rhode Island.
I want to be back in Britain.
Oh, it's a different... thing.
Interesting.
The witch's trials were the 1600s.
Oh dang, you're right.
Maybe.
Oh, what's going on in here?
Hello, sir?
Oh, can I pick up?
I found more ammunition!
Oh.
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
The servant is preoccupied with his duties.
Look at the face I'm giving at the camera.
He owns a musket for home defense.
As the founding fathers intended.
Oh!
Can I shoot this guy?
No.
Maximillian's medical journal.
Used to take notes on medical and pathological analyses.
Okay.
Yes, clean my floor.
No, no, no, no.
Come here, come here.
Clean my floor.
State of the art interior.
Outhouse!
Polished cheek and mahogany finish.
It is truly a sight to behold.
And experience.
Oh boy.
I didn't realize this was the bathroom.
The smell.
I'm getting out of here.
We could have just walked in on this guy.
Doing his...
Oh, that's what his duties are!
Oh my god!
The door to the servant's quarters is securely locked.
Maximillian, however, can't help but feel uneasy.
An ominous presence lurks behind that door.
Making the hairs on his neck stand on end.
I still have...
What is this music?
Oh yes!
The ghost!
A stained glass window.
Resplendent with bright colors and exquisite workmanship.
There is something odd about it.
Perhaps the curious detail of its shapes and content.
Or maybe that the sun is like a bloodied eye?
I don't know.
Might be the weird part about it.
It sounds like a bird is singing the song.
A gritty portrait of a man with an overbearing countenance.
Hardly a reassuring soul.
Maximillian wonders if that trait was prevalent in his ancestors.
Why can't I look at every painting?
I'm getting a lot of ammunition here.
I'm kind of nervous.
Skellies.
Okay.
Oh.
On the bedside table is an open letter.
I found a letter.
Letter number one.
A letter written with some precision and long hand.
Dear friend.
The antiquity of which you ask is indeed the tome of eternal darkness.
Or a copy of it.
At least.
The secrets are still hidden from me.
For I have been unable to read it.
As most scholars who have tried.
It will remain within the sanctity of the mansion.
For in the wrong hands it would be a powerful weapon.
Peruse it if you will.
But beware its magic.
It is a harsh mistress.
Erin Roivas.
Where's the book?
Oh my gosh.
There's a rune up here.
Stone tablet.
Yeah.
I'll take that.
Thank you.
What are you doing there guy?
The servant mutters under his breath.
Not realizing that Max is nearby.
He appears to be distressed at his lot in life.
Working all the time.
We've had the baby picture for centuries.
But he's not here yet.
State of the art.
A mirror's grim reflection.
Returns Max's questioning gaze.
His face racked with sleepless nights.
And a strange gleam in his eye.
Hint at a growingly odd demeanor.
Oh.
Ammunition.
There's a lot of ammunition here.
I mean good.
Thank goodness.
I just don't understand.
What are you doing?
Are you cleaning with your hand?
Like you're just brushing the dirt under the rug?
What is the...
What are your duties?
What do they entail?
Like what are you actually doing?
I don't understand.
There he goes again.
He's just brushing it under the dresser now.
He lost his context.
A luxurious fire warms the master bedroom.
Its flickering light gives both a soft aura to the room's somber decor.
And an ominous side to the shadows.
What happened to our cool music?
No!
Where's our cool music?
Someone's walking.
A maid!
Oh?
What is this?
Whoa!
I'm getting dizzy.
Why is he frozen over there?
Hello?
A maid.
Whilst performing her duties, the servant makes idle chit chat about the room's temperature.
Pulling from the weather deck.
Turn around, maid!
She's looking around.
She's like, what other wallpaper can I stroke?
Oh god.
Wait, the maid has trapped...
You guys, the maid has trapped me in.
Wait, I actually can't leave.
Wait, you guys!
You guys, you guys!
Oh thank god.
I was getting capitoned by the maid.
That was exciting.
Letter.
A letter scrawled by a panicked hand with clotted ink.
Forsaken by the ancients.
I dare not enter it for fear of my mortal soul.
I would suggest that you leave also.
Bring the book.
It is a far more potent tool than you have learned.
And may well swing the balance in our favor.
A.
Roivas.
Maid stuck!
Uh oh.
I think the house is...
Bad?
I think this is the same description that Alex gives it.
I'm confused why I was able to look over the banister like that.
Examine.
Like...
Oh my god.
I feel like I'm getting motion sickness from this.
I think this house is kind of bad, you guys.
I'm getting a bit of a feeling.
At least these guys keep the lights on.
Oh, another rune.
I'm getting all these runes.
But I'm not getting any...
Book?
Oh.
Is that a baseball bat?
A pump handle is sitting on the barrel inside the pantry.
I'll take that.
Cozy fireplace is the focal point of the kitchen.
Lending a good deal of warmth to the austere room at night.
Hello.
I think I'm a good...
Master.
With a kind smile, she asks if Maximilian has an appetite as she is preparing a hearty meal for the evening.
See?
She's so kind.
She's so nice.
What about you?
Are you nice to me?
Do you like me?
Whilst going about her duties, the servant casually remarks about a strange quality hanging in the air.
This odd comment makes Maximilian feel like something is quite amiss.
Why would she say that?
There's that other guy walking.
Why did the music stop?
Yippee!
We get the good music back!
Oh, this guy right here.
I wanted to...
Everybody's just sweeping with their hands.
I can't afford brooms?
I own this whole mansion and I can't afford a broom?
What is this?
Bidding Maximilian a courteous good day, the servant returns to his duties.
Hello, sir?
Good day to you, goodnight to you?
The servant inquires if Maximilian requires anything of service.
Oh.
Oh, yeah, I get it!
There's something written beneath the image.
When darkness spreads its wings before my master...
mmmm...
Anti-cool-esque.
Backwards-cool-esque.
Zellatoth's greatest foe.
The path to truth will be open.
Bird!
Oh, the true foe?
So it would be this one.
Aha!
Uh-oh.
Oh, enter secret passageway.
Wait, not yet, not yet, not yet.
The uncool S.
The cool Z.
Hold on.
We have a few more over here.
Sorry, I know I'm...
Oh!
Is anybody gonna...
Nobody's gonna comment on the sigil that's just on the wall, the glowing sigil.
An oil painting of the mansion's foyer hangs on the wall.
Sorry, foyer.
Max wonders why the artist would paint an inaccurate picture of one end of the room with such detail and clarity that it approaches realism.
What a strange thing.
Pokmon.
I see no sigil.
Shut up.
Foyay.
Foyette?
No, foyay.
Foyay!
Foyippee!
The illustration features a collection of strange line designs related to each other in a cyclical manner.
There appears to be some significance to it, but it isn't particularly evident.
The wall is decorated with a colored triangular design.
Kimi wa dare to kisu wo sunu?
Although Max has seen this...
I think I just understood why the song is called Triangular.
Is it because it's about a love triangle?
The first line is like, who are you going to kiss?
Kimi wa dare to kisu...
Oh my god.
It just occurred to me.
Oh my gosh!
This is all a macross, truly.
It's literally the plot.
I know, I just never thought of it.
I just never thought of it.
The wall is decorated with a colored triangular design.
Although Max has seen this particular embellishment.
Time and time again.
Its significance still evades him.
They didn't tell this guy anything.
Okay.
Now we may go into our tiny hole.
The love triangle.
So funny.
Here we go!
It's this room!
Cheryl or Ranka?
Ranka.
I think maybe if I were to watch it again, I would pick Cheryl.
But my heart is still Ranka.
A curled scroll of aged parchment sits atop the stack of dusty books.
It is covered with strange diagrams and writing.
Reveal invisible!
Woo!
Oh.
A saber!
Saber!
There's the book.
Oh.
Nothing?
Okay.
What else is in here?
A gun!
An aged flintlock pistol rests on a display stand fixed to the wall.
Flintlock pistol?
But we've been getting...
Wait, no.
We got revolver ammunition before.
Oh, now I can duel them!
I can duel wield!
Okay.
Let's grab the tome.
The way he's just standing at it.
Lying amidst the papers on the desk.
Oh my god.
Can I stop you?
I'm so sorry.
It's a strange leather-bound book.
Should Max pick up the book?
Yes.
Duel wielding, baby.
Oh!
Are you kidding me?
As Max lifts the tome of eternal darkness, a letter slips out from between the pages.
Deftly, Max catches it as it drops toward the floor.
Um...
Wait, but my people are gonna die!
The letter scrawled almost indes...
...cypherably by a wavering hand.
Dear friend.
As I suspected the ruins of...
Enga?
Tell your lads that blasted necropolis lie deep under the site of the mansion.
The accursed servants of Zelotath are so close I can almost hear their chittering!
What?
There is a secret opening in the basement and from there we can gain access.
I urge you to gather some men and seal it or better still destroy that damned place.
I have stowed something that you will find useful on the upper level.
Look to the light and you will find it.
Oh, yes.
Two shots.
Spins split on pistols.
This time I got two shots.
I wish that I could be at your side but my ailment worsens daily and I know that my time is short.
A.R.
I won't forgive you if you let that cute maid...
...maid die.
No, no, the other cute maid.
Okay, let's equip our guns.
Oh my god.
He's punching me!
I'm sorry.
This is...
This...
New weapon everybody.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
New weapon.
Oh my god.
Please, I'm stuck.
Please.
Please stop.
Stop following me so...
I'm going to switch to the sword.
Oh.
I'll charge you.
Servant!
Why must you...
Oh my god.
It's this...
It's this damn thing.
Oh my god, no.
Please.
No, don't open the door.
Attempt autopsy?
I can't believe this.
What am I...
A new entry has been placed in Maximilian's medical journal.
It can be accessed from the journal section of the tome.
What?
When the autopsy...
When an autopsy has been performed, Max can view the new entry by turning to the journal section of the tome and selecting autopsy at the bottom of the page.
Select the autopsy to view using up-down.
Pressing A will display it.
Whoa!
Would you prefer to do laps around this room or the MGS1 tower?
I think the MGS1 tower.
The creature wears the skin of people to protect itself.
Bone thief!
Oh.
Ah!
Yeah, take that!
Bozo.
Bone-zo!
I am gonna save real quick.
Since I forgot to do so before.
I'd love to reload during that battle.
Ow, ow, ow!
And also...
Reveal invisible.
Torn scroll with magical equipment.
Equations and notes.
So that's...
The one at the bottom is the one that is inside the guy.
That we're gonna have to shoot up, maybe.
This enchantment...
The invisible is rendered visible.
Use it wisely for some things are invisible for a reason.
Immortal kind are not meant to see them.
That's exciting.
That's kinda...
That's kinda fun.
I can't believe they turned on me, though!
I missed my old weapon.
What?
Why does it say zero?
Am I out of ammo?
Read the autopsies out this chapter?
Voiced?
Wait, what do you mean?
It needs to reload.
Wait, how do I reload it?
Oh!
Oh my god.
The way you hold stuff is just...
Oh gosh!
There's only...
Oh my god.
RELOAD!
Oh, this is so...
This is so...
RELOAD!
Oh...
Oh gosh.
Looks like kinda...
Oh my gosh.
No!
The main is attacking me!
I'll chill.
Oh gosh.
My controls!
Please!
This guy seems kinda scared.
I'm not gonna let him die.
Wait.
I'm gonna go back in here?
And I'm actually going to, um...
Do this spell?
And we're gonna reload?
Oh, encha...
Wait, I can enchant it?
But I should do...
Maybe green?
Oh!
I have toti...
Um...
Spell list...
All right.
Cast...
Green?
Want red?
Yeah.
But we don't have red.
So this is all I've got.
I know I want red, but I don't have red, so I have to use what I've got.
Oh my god.
Please.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I'm in trouble!
I'M IN TROUBLE!
What are you...?
What?
Sir.
This is a great star.
This is such a great star.
This is just a wonderful star.
This is just really great.
I'm trapped in here!
They're all camping!
I think I have to use my sword.
I don't know.
No, there's no way to loop around.
We're just gonna...
If I die?
I die.
Oh my god.
Oh!
I'm so sorry!
No!
Mister!
I'm so both.
This is so...
I'm so bone.
Can you imagine trying to do this with one life?
Goofy at camera angles.
I know!
That was so bad.
The bone thieves are nasty.
They are.
I hate those guys the most.
I don't like them.
Good thing I saved.
The darkness comes!
One life, one mint was only a dream.
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know which one's better.
I'm just gonna go with green.
Enter by...
Selatan.
They bl... They spam their insanity...
I know, right?
They spam the insanity blasts and they're so annoying and...
Icky, icky.
You consent, Selatan.
I picked green because it's my favorite.
That's what I did!
Though I probably would always pick green.
I'm not gonna lie.
Okay.
If I enchant my sword too...
So just in case I need to take it out...
Enter by...
Selatan.
It's hard though.
Oh my gosh.
This guy's cowering.
Weeee!
And then the maid.
Oh my god.
I only got to reload.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Reload.
Maybe I have time now.
Okay.
Nice!
You took it out!
I'm posing.
Yippee!
No...
You took it out.
Okay.
Thank you.
I just discovered the invisible spell.
Is the maid... is she... good?
Is she...
How are you?
Oh, you're... oh... what?
Excuse me?
You're just...
Eyes wide with fright, his head twists frantically left and right as if trying to see some invisible horror stalking him.
Have you no eyes?
Can't you see it?
He cries.
Why are you cleaning the floor then?
Business as usual.
Oh, I can't sit here.
I am gonna go back into the room though.
That we came from and save so that we don't have to do that all over again.
Since it was pretty clean the way we took care of it.
Save, save, save.
Cast the invisible spell.
Yes.
Alright.
Where are you, buddy?
Come here.
I'm gonna save you.
Wait, but it's reveal invisible.
Wait, which one?
Woah.
Is my maid okay?
I can't tell.
I don't wanna go too close to her.
I'm scared.
But I know this door over here.
Oh.
Or not.
Am I...
Are my bullets reloaded?
I can't tell.
I guess so.
Cast it in front of the symbol.
HeroCon record seven times.
Hmm.
Oh.
So...
Green?
Okay, I wonder if it's the same as the...
I wish I could see the camera so...
I wonder if it's the same as the fireplace?
Uh oh.
No!
No, maid!
Oh, shoot.
What?
I thought I...
Oh, shoot.
I only have one bullet at a time.
Hello?
Stop punching me!
Reload!
Oh, shit.
Oh, gosh.
I hate...
I hate these creatures so...
Much!
Why can't I only do one bullet at a time now?
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Don't these guys...
Dodge these things?
Don't they dodge...
Hold on.
I think they...
Equip.
I'm
out!
Nice.
Yeah, the bone thieves dodge and stuff.
Okay, well our maid...
Was so sad.
That was the most sad thing ever.
There we go.
Hahaha.
He just kicked me.
He kicked me.
What's this guy...
Maximilian...
Maximilian means business.
Okay?
Enter by...
Celadon.
He means business, baby.
Oh, yeah.
Let's also...
You are sent.
Celadon.
Look at him.
Look at his stance.
Look at him just...
He keeps...
He's like... Even if I was one of the bone thieves, I'd be like, I'm not messing with that guy.
He's insane.
He's dual wielding.
I stopped buying books at yard sales.
Alright, I know probably doing that is whatever.
But I like to just have it.
Okay, he said something upstairs.
There's probably guys wandering now.
It was my gun that's making it glow.
I was like, why is it glowing?
That's so mysterious.
Here!
You guys...
I don't want to tell you what I just read that word as instead of excitement.
The music is literally me reading it.
Despite his excitement at the discovery, Max senses something odd about it.
A sense of evil.
But they...
Oh my god.
Finish him.
Dang, this thing takes those out.
Nice.
Oh no, that's why they replaced the painting probably.
Or the...
What's it called?
Not painting.
Stained glass.
That's why it's different.
Why is it...
I appreciate that this guy's finishing move is essentially whacking it with his cane.
And kicking them in the ribs.
Classy.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Our letter.
A paper envelope sealed with a glob of melted wax.
An odd rune is pressed into the wax.
There appears to be something heavy inside.
Inside the envelope is a letter addressed to one of Max's father's aides.
And a basement key.
Where's the basement?
Um...
The letter written in a scrawling hand reads, Dear friend.
As I expected, the beasts are drawing closer to our discovery.
They want the book for themselves, it seems.
And do not want us to have it in our possession.
I've taken steps to ensure that our ilk will not touch the key in this envelope.
Should you fall prey to their claws.
The envelope containing the basement key has been sealed with a corrosive magic.
If one not aligned to us tries to handle it, it will be released...
It will be released, inflicting pain, suffering, and a grievous blow to their sanity.
Should they have any left, be swept with your task.
A.R.
Alrighty.
Um...
Downstairs?
What's happening?
My sanity?
Oh!
Another guy!
Are you kidding me?
Wait, is it still enchanted?
I can't tell.
Oh my god.
My... yes, they are still enchanted.
Yeah, look at that.
Okay.
I'm trying to get his eye.
Oh shit!
I can't... I can only...
Okay.
Come on.
Not the best place, maybe.
Okay, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Ouch, ouch.
Oh my god.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go upstairs, maybe?
He's just chasing after me!
Not even a moment's rest?
Okay, this is good.
Actually.
Here.
Okay.
Oh,
whoa.
Oh gosh.
He gets me every time.
That's just like a big...
There we go.
We got a red rod!
Oh.
Maybe.
You okay?
You okay, Maximilian?
Elias?
Maximilliam?
Maximus?
What's his name?
I hear someone sweeping.
Okay, I think it's our guy.
I can't... I don't know why he's still normal.
Wait, will this help?
Absorb...
Recover spell!
We can now heal!
I think.
Recover?
Nope.
Assign?
Red to here.
New autopsy time?
But where?
Oh wait, actually, what if I do the spell of Reveal Invisible?
Will we see the guy that we just killed?
Will we see him?
Oh, I thought that was it.
Nope.
Dang.
I tried.
Okay.
Spell list...
Reveal Invisible...
No, new spell...
Red...
Area...
Project?
Is that it?
Nezumi!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
I will always...
Spend...
Spectacle!
It's me!
Spell nine, baby!
Why does it feel like an action game all of a sudden?
Oh wait, spell nine...
Okay, hold on.
Spellist...
Reveal Invisible, check.
It was, uh...
Narakoth and Red Gormur!
It was Gormur.
Narakoth and Red Gorm War.
Narakoth... Narakoth and...
You don't need to redo spells.
It's automatic.
What do you mean redo?
Oh, wait.
Yay!
Ghost made Mei cry.
Good evening Minto!
How am I feeling?
I'm alright.
I'm a little sleepy actually.
Recover enchant item.
Hold on.
I'm checking everything though.
Anterbork and Magor Mawr.
Anterbork...
There.
There we go.
Okay.
Now we can cast our things to be red as well.
Our items.
And we can heal.
We're good.
The color existing spells stay and have all colors as you unlock them.
You don't need to recreate the same spells each time.
Oh, wait.
Actually...
Reveal.
Recover enchant item.
I want to check though.
I did the green one earlier because I thought maybe we could do it...
Because we went to the Sephia world, I thought maybe he was invisible.
And we'd be able to go there.
Oh, it's locked.
Wait!
The basement key.
God, these camera angles.
They're...
Oh!
They're very Resident Evil and they scare me.
Wait.
I'm gonna equip the saber.
I'm going to spell.
Enchant.
Cast.
On the saber.
Yippee!
And then I'm going to...
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh
my god.
No, it's this...
No, please.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't fight.
There we go.
Finish him.
Yeah.
Kick him.
Okay.
And...
Yeah.
Fight him.
Kill him.
Very Resident Evil.
Camera angles.
Finish him.
Nice.
Yeah.
Take him out.
Is this one my sanity?
Oh no.
This...
This one's my sanity.
There we go.
We're not slightly tilted anymore.
Okay.
We're in the basement.
Oh.
What's that?
Dirty water.
Scroll of paper.
Oh.
Damage field.
Is that the one I cast earlier?
Or did earlier?
No.
What is spell nine?
A tattered scroll lined with curious writing and diagrams.
It reads, this incantation exerts a force of mystical power within the confines of its runes.
Nothing may enter till it is dispelled.
Try spell nine.
So it's just like a big...
It's just a big...
Like...
Spell nine.
N-I-N-E.
Give me!
Thanks for two more hands!
Oh.
We got more rooms.
I think I'm gonna rearrange my quick...
Oh.
What did I...
Examine what?
Oh.
There.
The pump!
We got the pump though.
Was there anything over here?
Just checking.
All right.
All right guys.
My pump.
Oh my god.
It's so ghastly.
It's ghostly.
The pump's all by itself.
Good morning, thanks to the three birds!
That pump?
Come on, baby America!
Oh.
Spell nine.
No!
Oh.
I messed up.
I forgot that I need to stay in the circle.
I forgot.
Bye bye.
Damage fields!
Yay!
What's this guy?
Disgusting.
Thank you.
I'm gonna check the... the autopsies right now.
Maximilian's awesome!
He's so strong!
Let's see.
Wait.
No, I wanna check it.
Oh, it's in the...
Check.
Oh, here it is.
Autopsy.
Analysis of Mantorok Zombie.
A living human corpse.
It has no special attributes or weaknesses.
No special attributes?
That's so sad.
Everybody's special.
It is very weak.
Composed of dried sinew and skin.
Zellototh Zombie.
Limbs regrow as phantom and...
Phantom?
There's no voiceover?
Is there supposed to be?
I remember there was voiceover.
No voiceover in this chapter.
Oh.
Um...
Yeah, my bad.
It's after the chapter ends.
Ah.
Limbs regrow as phantom entities when severed, causing deep-rooted insanity in the observers.
Oh, that's why they turn... green?
Are those boobs?
Does this zombie have boobs?
Would.
The wrappings of the mummy are hardly combustible and catch fire easily.
Yes!
Yes, we knew that.
Sure does.
Zomboobs.
I put my hands up to play my song.
The butterflies fly away.
Nodding my head like, yeah.
Moving my...
Moving my wrappings like, yeah.
I put my hands up to play my song.
I know I'm gonna be okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a party in Zellototh's cave.
Whoa!
Why is there...
Why is this...
In my basement?
Max is incredulous at the sight.
A desolate ruin of a fantastic city built into a huge naturally formed cave.
Judding spires and looming buildings poke through the dense fog.
Light ebbs through the city, crackling in the wake of the energy.
Spelling from a light source held aloft by unseen forces.
JPEG city.
I love the PNG.
Long,
long staircase.
Ooh, it's really dark down there.
Like an inter...
Oh.
Maximilian coming in here like, I'm about to mess up this town!
Oh, what is that?
Unfazed.
What if I do one too?
Wait.
Oh no!
Mine didn't reach long enough!
Save?
Oh.
Um.
It did hit!
Oh, it did?
I don't think I can save though.
It won't let me.
Um.
I think we're just gonna have to...
Uh.
Yeah.
A flinch and go...
Okay, so it did glow red.
Okay, um.
Uh.
What was I gonna say?
When did I...
When was the last time I saved?
I think it was before I went into the basement.
So it wasn't that long ago.
I don't think it'll let me in here.
Can I just go?
Can I attack him?
In fact, I'm just gonna enchant my sword.
Every time I have to go into this...
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Thank you.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
I got this, too.
What's all this stuff?
If you have the right ones...
You can...
...you can...
If you have the right ones...
Yeah, you can...
...you can...
I mean, no, if someone has the right ones...
...you can do whatever you want with them.
Good job.
Oh, no.
It's okay!
It's okay.
Yeah.
I can't do anything.
Maybe I can do something.
What's it doing?
Oh, it's summoning.
It's summoning guys.
Where are you going?
I killed your guy.
Nice.
Oh.
Oh, run closer.
Oh, you got him.
I think.
I'm speaking Latin.
Oh, nice.
Whoa.
Sounded like it was something from Faith.
I don't need to save you guys.
Park on Cynthia's Park.
The accursed beast was dead.
But not without its toll on me.
That was but one.
And there was an entire city of them.
Oh, you're right.
I did not hope to fight them all alone.
Oh, no.
I knew I had to get help.
I knew there was a way.
I just had to find it.
Can I summon my own demons?
Oh, three months later.
No way.
Three months later.
I tried.
I tried to tell them.
But they won't listen to me.
Damn them.
Damn their eyes.
The rats.
Can you believe me?
Strange creatures.
The world in power from unseen foes.
No, Maximus.
Death.
Darkness.
They left me in a room.
A room with rats.
Instead, they cheered.
Killed me into this forsaken place.
A place of empty souls and fevered thoughts.
Reeking of fetter and decay.
Thinking me mad with delirium.
I'm not going to die.
The fools cast away their hopes of salvation by locking me in this damned asylum.
May the rats eat your eyes!
I am now lost to your cause!
The darkness comes!
It will damn us all!
May the rats eat your eyes!
Yeah!
Huey.
It's literally me.
The darkness comes!
That was intense.
How do you feel about that, Alex?
That was...
To be continued.
The battle is won but the war...
The war against the darkness rages on!
This isn't really happening.
I gotta restore my sanity.
Sanity check.
I thought for real it was actually going to be like...
Continue to the next game!
That was so awesome.
Cool.
So now we have the spell to reveal the door.
And insert disc two, everybody.
Yeah.
Eternal darkness two.
Oh.
That was...
Never happened.
Wasn't it...
Wasn't it like there was a spiritual successor and then like that had to get cancelled or something?
There's still this whole room.
That...
I'm still not sure what to do here.
So we'll just ignore it for now.
Save.
Thank you.
The dresser.
Yes!
Maybe now we can...
Okay.
So we can...
So we have the door.
We have the door.
Down here.
Then we have the dresser.
All the autopsies.
There's so much.
You guys are like, don't forget this.
Don't forget that.
Minto.
Oh.
Guardians.
Gibbering insanity.
Wrought in flesh as though an artist had sculpted it.
Created from nothing by their mistress, Zelototh.
A cannibal.
A canvas as grotesque as any.
Their bodies made no sense.
No heads.
No organs.
An empty husk, devoid of the trappings of nature.
But it walked.
It sang.
It shrieked.
A mockery of reason, both natural and mental.
A blasphemy from beyond the veil.
The veil has opened.
And we should not see beyond.
We...
We weren't meant to.
Never...
Ever meant to.
Oh, give us the blessing of ignorance.
The happiness of oblivion.
Innocence can only be tainted.
Never returned.
Oh my god.
I couldn't even say anything through it.
He just sounded so awesome.
Ten out of ten VA.
Holy cow.
Wait, does he do this for all of them?
Corpses.
Lumbering.
Rotting cadavers.
What contrivance could have wrought this?
This...
This abomination.
Disease science.
Blasphemous occult rituals.
How can something so, so dead yet be so alive and hungry?
I lust for flesh.
Human flesh.
Such a lust for flesh.
And feast upon all the sweet breads a man has to offer.
Wow.
Zombie.
Neither the embalming salve of their wrappings nor the numbness of death could override the dominating madness that is Zelototh.
Zelototh.
Controlled.
Prodded into an existence by an incessant cacophony of voices penetrating every level of their psyches.
These corpses are coerced into life.
It's like method acting.
Ambling.
Moaning.
Shrieking.
Wait, I want to see this.
No, wait, hold on.
I wanted to read it.
A curious lack of internal organs mean no way of inflicting critical damage.
Gibbering insanity.
Sorry.
I just wanted to read it real quick.
The devils inside the servants' skulls were trying to kill me.
They plotted behind doors, locked and barred.
These guys are the worst.
And planned the downfall of the human race.
The worst, the worst, the worst, the worst.
I took care of the ones around me.
Stopped their plans.
There are others.
I'm sure.
Out there.
Manipulating us.
Secreting madness inside our very heads.
While our souls are pushed into the corners of our skulls.
Watching as our hands do tasks that we have no control over.
No.
Horrible.
Things.
I can't.
We must purge them from our midst.
Kill them all.
Cut them.
Burn them.
It's the only way.
I know.
I've.
Done it.
It.
Works.
Oh my god.
No.
Oh my.
It's.
Holy cow.
Oh.
If you don't plan on doing multiple playthroughs, you should look up the other autopsies for the other god enemy variants.
I haven't decided yet, but thank you.
I will think about that for.
So now we use the red here, right?
Spell list.
Maybe reveal invisible, cast the red one.
Maybe?
Aha!
There we go.
And then.
Our dresser key.
The voice director probably just said, bro, just cook.
I know.
Oh, use the dresser key.
Ask your doctor about Xelataz.
What do we get?
Oh.
Inside is a chrome finish revolver.
And a tattered paint.
Oh.
And a page from the Tome of Eternal Darkness.
Yes.
We got a revolver!
Oh my gosh.
It's the best weapon ever made.
A journey into darkness.
Park on.
Located within its grave.
As we suspected.
It shall be retrieved at once.
Be wary.
The power of Mantarok lingers still.
Corroding the universe around its tomb.
It will doubtlessly be guarded after these seven centuries.
The beast has not been contained.
Mr. Beast.
I can assure you that my binding of Mantarok, fueled by your very own power, will be enough.
It is not your sword.
It is the sorcery that we doubt, Augustus.
The power of the dead god.
It's your competence.
Best chapter in the end of time.
How can you, Amira Jones, comprehend what that entity represents?
Or what power it can wield?
We know not.
And we know more than thou.
Your future depends on me, Majesty.
Without me to open the gates...
Yes.
Be quick.
Lest our power and our faith in you...
No.
He is calling us from the right.
Always to uplift...
The voice acting in this is so good.
Now, I...
I am seen differently.
Stairs.
Gosh, the voice acting in this is crazy.
All right, then.
Before we...
Before we continue?
The cutscenes change depending on which god you choose to?
Really?
I like the one we got, though.
She's really cool.
I guess for this part, we wouldn't really know...
We wouldn't really know which one would reveal the door, I think.
Oh, ouch.
My bad.
You are assigned to take a bow.
Reveal invisibility?
Yeah, but which one would it be?
We have three of them.
Try them all.
With textures.
But I feel like it would show...
I feel like...
I feel like it would show, you know?
I feel like maybe we're not ready for it yet.
Oh, just kidding.
Sorry.
I saw the little sigil on the ground there and I thought it was correct.
Spell nine?
Spell nine!
Which flavor?
Does this one take out the...
I'm gonna try it again.
Dang, I thought it'd take out the force field.
We have damage field.
Enchant item, recover...
What?
Damage field work, maybe?
Boo!
Okay.
Oh well.
Well then.
Very cool.
I'm going to start the next chapter, but I'm going to end it before we get too far into it.
And then, what chapter is this actually?
I don't even know.
Chapter of darkness.
Yeah.
Needs more power, god.
So true.
It's true.
Wait, let's see.
Maybe we can see here.
Oh no.
Cin-cinema.
Cinema.
If you like voice acting, that goes hard, try Legacy of Kainser's.
Ooh.
I don't know that one actually.
The main character for the next chapter is actually voiced by an actor for Jack Bauer.
Oh.
That one is Neil.
You actually got me!
Mr. Yuta!
You actually got me.
Later chapters are going to be fun if you really like this one.
Oh yay.
Wait, this one coming up or the one that I just did.
Because I really liked the one I just did.
The ancients influence was incredible.
From all walks of life to all parts of the world.
Indiana Jones time.
Their tendrils crept and wrought their insidious damage.
Their prisons decayed constantly.
We're getting closer and closer to our present time.
It's playing as Vulcan.
What do you mean?
1983!
Oh my god.
Hello?
Why is Skull Face walking with us?
It's Snake and Skull Face!
Satellite Dana was correct!
I hear Mint died.
What are you talking about?
It's an optional and kind of OP thing you can get in this chapter.
You might want to consider looking it up.
Hey!
Yeah!
Punch him!
Take his gun before you run away?
What are you doing?
Oh!
Nice shot!
What's wrong with you?
Stormtrooper aim!
You are a scholar, Dr. Lindsey.
Not a warrior.
In that regard, I have several centuries more experience than you.
Don't be a fool.
Die quietly.
And you will not suffer.
You cannot escape me, Lindsey.
This place will be your tomb.
Just as it is Mantarox.
Hello?
What the hell?
Kill him!
Wait!
Wait a second!
Is this a boss battle right at the front?
No way.
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
Hello?
I was just gonna start the...
the chapter?
Not expecting this?
It's just draining and draining and draining.
I got five bullets left.
I can't hear you over your sludge.
His face!
There we go.
Gotta bait it to open up.
Oh gosh.
Can
I get more bullets?
Please?
I don't know if that actually did anything.
Oh my god.
Oh.
You're a little late.
Your timing, please.
Uh oh.
Um...
Oh, I can reload.
Oh, okay.
We're fine.
We're fine, everybody.
Where is it?
Where'd he go?
Hello?
I don't think that did anything.
We got our archaeology...
Archaeologist brush.
A torch.
Some ammo.
Oh, a shotgun.
Wait.
Oh, these are shotgun shells.
I was like, oh, we're fine.
On the shotgun ammo.
We got a...
A pistol.
Dang.
Our guy is low.
Shotgun kills it in two hits.
That's okay.
I don't need to...
I'm not speedrunning.
It's all good.
I'm getting the hell out of here.
Lindsey has no intention of leaving the temple.
Just kidding.
He's determined to get to the artifact before Augustine does.
No one crosses Edwin Lindsey.
Kuwabara kuwabara.
I should probably save.
And that was a fun start to the chapter.
Why are they doing him so dirty like that?
Why does he look like Dr. Edwin?
What is this one?
Oh, it's her.
I was confused.
Kiki Ricky.
He's pogging.
I don't know about that.
Wait, this is actually Volgen's voice actor?
No way.
Oh!
I just realized we're here!
Statue of a seated goddess where her neck and wrists should bear jewelry.
There are merely worn grooves and flecks of bronze dust.
Have they been stolen by grave robbers?
Actually, by me!
I stole it!
Wow, this is the area where we were Oh, look at that girl!
Wait, will we have to fight her, I wonder?
Okay, guys.
Uh-oh.
I have stamina now.
Interesting.
Thick layer of dust obscures the tiles on the floor.
Bronze bracelet has been discovered
Don't look at the camera.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, I'm gonna keep playing if I don't stop here.
I'm going to keep playing.
I'm going to keep playing if I don't stop here.
I will stop here, everybody.
Um...
I'm thinking, what?
Two more streams?
For the rest of it?
Because we got through three, I think three yesterday, three today.
Or so?
Two sounds right, yeah.
Oh yeah, two and a half.
That's true, yeah.
Um...
So...
Yeah.
We'll see.
Two to three?
Yeah, maybe if we have to do a third one.
Yeah!
This was so fun.
I'm loving all the different stuff that we're learning.
Like, now that we got all...
Oh, we don't have the tome yet.
So I was like, where's my spells?
Um, once we get...
Once we get our...
Oh, why can you hear it?
Once we get all the stuff...
Or like, we have all our spells now.
We're getting cooler weapons and everything.
Have a good night, Min.
Thank you!
And we're getting through stuff in the mansion, so it's getting more exciting.
I'm shocked that whatever is going on is all underneath us.
I'm very like...
I'm still confused what's going on, but I feel...
Um...
Also...
A little more...
Also, paragon, paragon, paragon, paragon.
I think.
Yeah.
So I have no idea what's going on, but this has been really fun.
Great job on getting a hold of the game mechanics.
Thank you!
Yeah, I've...
I think I've mostly...
I'm getting more and more used to it.
So, paragon, paragon, paragon.
Two!
Thanks, TryPrincess!
Thank you.
Um...
And the chapters have been really...
I think I really like that each chapter kind of introduces something different.
And, um...
Has been different.
A different feel.
It's so crazy.
This game is so crazy, but I'm really enjoying it.
I can see why people really like it.
But, um...
Notice I haven't been audible all stream?
Oh!
I realize...
That I had it turned off.
My bad.
But I can hear them.
Sorry.
Oopsie.
They're only audible on my side.
Sorry.
My bad.
I did it so that I wouldn't be confused about sound.
But it should be okay now.
I mean, now you can hear them.
But I'm also ending the stream.
I haven't been called a simp once.
Oh!
You're a simp!
Um...
Arigato!
What's another one?
Oh.
Oh, wait!
I did it!
I should add...
Please
wrap it up.
Shut the hell up!
Shut up, Murphy!
Um...
You said you would add it like two months ago.
You're right.
I need to add that one.
Um...
Why is the zombie caked up?
Damn!
You're right!
Holy cow!
I never knew that I needed a half-skelly, half-human in my life before.
Or in my afterlife.
Toot-toot-a-roll.
Shut up.
Shut up!
Toot-toot-a-roll.
There you said it.
I'll add toot-toot-a-roll.
I'll add it.
Thank you guys.
You're a simp!
Thank you guys for watching.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
I'll see you guys later.
Have a good night.
Bye-bye.
Thank you.
Oh my
god.
Thanks for the five gifted.
I didn't realize you could still hear me either.
Okay.
Now I turn off my...
Arigato.
Thank you.
See you.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye now.
Bye!